in london this morning huge crowds have
gathered to see queen elizabeth's coffin
carried in a grand procession through
the city this morning last night a
motorcade brought the queen for the last
time to buckingham palace where she has
lived for most of her 96 years holly
williams is outside the palace holly
good morning to you what are we going to
see later today
good morning gail well just over two
hours from now the queen's coffin will
pass from her family that's the royal
family to the nation it will pass down
this road just behind me drawn on a gun
carriage through central london to the
palace of westminster where she will lie
in state until her funeral on monday
the queen was born in london and last
night she came home
flown by a military transporter
accompanied by her only daughter
princess anne
the princess said in a statement that
she was fortunate to share the last 24
hours of her dearest mother's life to my
mother the queen
thank you
the cortes drove slowly in the twilight
through the streets of the british
capital and the english reign
to buckingham palace for one final night
inside a glimpse of family members king
charles as well as harry and megan it's
so moving it's so touching you know and
i'm glad i was here
to see feelings for myself to see
history being done the queen's all we've
ever known
since we've never
so it's never been any different it's
always been a queen
it's hard to believe that just over
three months ago the queen appeared on
the balcony of buckingham palace to meet
her adoring public
the platinum jubilee marked her record
70-year reign
[Applause]
the concert at the palace was
star-studded
[Applause]
a whimsical celebration of her service
and her trademarks
[Applause]
her son and successor king charles iii
was in northern ireland yesterday he's
been traveling across the country in
recent days meeting what are now his
people
[Music]
the last time this country buried a
monarch was 1952
the late queen's father george vi
a guard watches over
the sleeping king then the public lined
up to pay their final respects
this time around
750 000 people are expected in a line
nearly five miles long
behind the queen's coffin today will
walk king charles princess william and
harry along with other members of the
royal family kate the queen consort
camilla and megan are all expected to
travel by car
tony
holly williams for us holly thank you
very much